la sélection pour les prochains
championnats du monde est tombé la
fédération française a dévoilé les
visages des pistards qui représenteront
la france en pologne du 27 février au 3
mars on retrouvera en vitesse et
expérimenté michael d'almeida grégory
baugé
ils seront associés au jeune sébastien
vigier 21 ans et ryan et là le 20 ans ça
c'était très important pour moi que
cette passation de pouvoir se fasse
sereinement pendant cette olympiade
c'est ce qui se passe ça veut dire que
nos anciens sont encore bien là vous
voyez sont hormis sélection beaucoup
d'entre eux peuvent prétendre être
également à tokyo donc c'est très bien
mais en même temps on sent la génération
suivante qui continue à progresser et
qui est particulièrement active pour
gagner ces places dans les sélections
dans cette nouvelle génération
retrouvera notamment chez les féminines
matile de gros 19 ans championne
d'europe du quirinal et et 2018 la
sportive espère maintenant remporté ses
deux premières médailles mondiales chez
les élites conquérante
à l'heure actuelle je me sens vraiment
bien la préparation s'est bien passée
maintenant on peaufine tout ça donc avec
mon entraîneur voilà on n'est plus sûr
de la qualité que de la quantité le
travail a été fait maintenant bas on
verra un peu
comment ça va se passer mais en tout cas
j'espère vraiment informés sur ces
modèles l'année dernière lors des
précédents championnats du monde la
france a remporté seulement deux
médailles de bronze aux pays bas la
fédération française on espère le double
à pruszkow en pologne